- March 2020...
A deadly virus sweeps around the world.
Overnight, our lives
are put on pause.
- Today, the WHO declared a pandemic...
- ...issuing a stay home, stay safe order.
- ...directing all of our residents
to quite simply stay at home.
(uplifting music plays)
- But as we stop,
remarkable things start
to change in the natural world.
- With the clear skies,
for the first time in a lifetime,
we can see the Himalayas.
(camera shutter clicks)
- With beaches closed to humans,
these animals
were nesting at a more successful rate
than we've ever seen.
(whales singing)
- One vocalizing, and than the other...
I'd never heard that before.
- From the start of lockdown,
across five continents,
we have recorded a global experiment
of epic proportions
that has shown us
if we choose,
we can transform
the health of the planet...
...for all.